so as we continue our discussion on
darkside war we pick up with the events
following Batman's acquisition of the
mobius chair and ascension to godhood
and transition to a character named
Kalibak so longtime DC readers are well
aware of who Kalibak is and the fact
that he dates back to the original
appearance of Darkseid in 1971 with Jack
Kirby's first new gods story now where
the original publications depicted
Kalibak as the firstborn son whose
mother was killed by desaad under Hera
the mother of Darkseid who looked to
manipulate her son into taking over New
Genesis within the new 52 like
Steppenwolf in desaad Kalibak has not
been provided a backstory the only
information we have on his character is
that he's the son of Darkseid but the
identity of his mother is a mystery to
us now where John's may or may not
answer this question in truth I'd argue
that because of the events that will
transpire regarding his character we
don't really need to know any of this
but the introduction of Calla back into
this story comes by way of Steppenwolf
who's been sent to have Kalibak fight
alongside the forces of apocalypse
during their invasion of Earth now the
inclusion of Cala back comes against the
opinions of Steppenwolf who views
Darkseid son as reckless and headstrong
with no real thought to how his actions
impact a bigger picture and what I mean
here is that during the events of Earth
two worlds end when the forces of
apocalypse invaded the earth two
continuity when the battle unfolded
Kalibak showed no concern for the forces
of apocalypse and often decimated the
men of his own ranks in order to attack
those he considered foes as a result he
often creates panic on the battlefield
destroying the battle plans of
Steppenwolf something I'd also like you
to notice here is that Kalibak is
allowed a little more leeway regarding
his view of Darkseid and that despite
his actions of disobeying the orders of
Steppenwolf on the battlefield he's
still allowed to join the fight against
the anti-monitor now a question I would
ask here is whether calleb acts
attendance is due to the fact that he's
Darkseid son or because Darkseid
recognizes the threat that anti-monitor
presents and is quite literally pulling
out all the stops and an attempt to
ensure victory but regardless of the
reasons the fact remains that because of
his bloodlust combined with his vast
strength and combat prowess
Kalibak is an asset for virtually
whoever he's fighting for but from here
we jump back to Batman and his
acquisition of the Mobius chair now
something I really enjoyed about this
particular moment is that John seems to
be presenting the Mobius chair to be as
much of a drug as a source of
information what I mean here is that
like Gollum and
Baggins from the Lord of the Rings who
were obsessed with the One Ring and
needed it both emotionally and
physically that as conversation with the
League provides the same sentiment with
his character what this conversation
reveals of the möbius chair does not
know the identity of the anti-monitor
Batman also says things like he needs
the chair and that it provides
information that they couldn't get any
other way in addition to this Hal Jordan
offers to use his Lantern ring as an
alternative to Batman's direct
interaction with the chair but the offer
is declined in lieu of the claim that
Bruce has more interaction with Darkseid
and apocalypse than anyone else now this
particular instance is a reference to
the Robin rises story in the new 52
where Bruce travelled to apocalypse
following the death of a son Damian in
an effort to reclaim his body because
the story saw him traversing his way
through apocalypse and eventually
confronting Darkseid
that man's journey gave him first-hand
experience on Darkseid and apocalypse in
a way that no one else has from here we
travel back to apocalypse with Superman
and Lex Luthor now in the new 52
Superman's own experience in apocalypse
happened during the first arc of the
Justice League during Darkseid's
appearance and his battle with the
league because Clark had spent a limited
amount of time here in the form of a
couple minutes or less he has no real
understanding of how this location
affects his powers and so what Jon's
does here is provide us with the full
measure of what Superman is capable of
as the two make their way through the
landscape because the only way to travel
back to earth is by way of a mother box
which acts as a teleporter between
apocalypse and the rest of the
multiverse whether to investigate the
area they also learn the Superman's
x-ray vision doesn't work in addition to
this because Darkseid had informed his
slaves that whoever kills Superman will
receive their freedom both Lex and Clark
are set upon by an army of slaves vying
for the opportunity to be free now the
battle between Superman and Lex against
the slaves is very important for their
characters not because of the slaves
themselves but because it highlights a
fundamental difference between Clark and
Lex and for Superman the slaves of this
world aren't there by choice and are
simply the inhabitants of conquered
worlds by way of dark sides forces as
such their actions of attacking or out
of desperation to escape their hellish
existence more so than out of malice
however for Lex there's no real
differentiation between the inhabitants
of this world and the being who rules it
and instead he believes they are all
guilty and should be punished
accordingly however at the conclusion of
the fight
the reason for why Superman's x-ray
vision didn't work is revealed to be due
to the fact that apocalypse has no
sunlight meaning that Superman can be
killed while he's here now the most
logical question to ask is that if
there's no sunlight how is it the
Superman was able to use super strength
in his fight against the slaves to be
honest I would argue that the lack of
sunlight simply keeps Superman from
recharging and that like a battery
Superman will retain his abilities until
he simply runs out of juice
so to speak from here we jump back to
earth with Grail and the anti-monitor
because they will a dark side was to
locate Morena black for the purpose of
finding Grail the actions of Grail in
this moment effectively create a
shortcut using a pentagram of sorts and
invoking Amazonian magic her goal is to
keep her into the bargain with
anti-monitor
by making her location known to Darkseid
luring him to earth where the
anti-monitor lies in wait now
transitioning back to Batman and the
lead the conversation between the group
and their hunt for answers in this
section actually covers information that
we already have but their questions
range from how Braille was able to use
Barry Allen as a dimensional doorway to
how she was able to open a portal for
anti-monitor using the ring of Jessica
Cruz now where Batman doesn't answer
these questions and instead chooses to
answer winter woman's question on the
history of Grail and marina black the
use of very Alan and Jessica's ring will
eventually serve as a subplot later in
the story but before any of them can
continue the group is met with the
arrival of scot free now the situation
as it appears to the eyes of Scott is of
both intrigue and cynicism what I mean
here is that because Metron had used
Scott as a bargaining chip in brokering
peace between Darkseid and highfather
Scott harbors no love for Metron however
the fact that he has been removed from
his chair and replaced by Batman begs
the question of how and why this
happened now where Metron states that
this was done against his will Scott
makes a case that it may have all
transpired as a result of the plan that
Metron is set in motion however rather
than providing us with an answer to
whether or not this is all true the plan
of Metron instead John shifts the focus
of the story to the arrival of Darkseid
because Scott realizes that a battle
between dark side and anti-monitor would
lay waste to the planet and possibly the
universe itself and because the league
does not possess the knowledge or power
to defeat anti-monitor the only option
they have is to force anti-monitor to
leave now something to keep in mind here
is that from the perspective of Scott
the
were able to force Darkseid out of the
reality in their initial conflict
however the ending of their first battle
with Darkseid came when cyborg hacked
into a mother box and used it to
teleport Darkseid away
however Darkseid could have returned at
any point and destroy the planets
inhabitants but because his only
interest was in finding Grail he simply
left the planet alone since he didn't
believe that she was there what this
means is that Scott is basically
operating on incomplete information and
that the situation as its unfolding
cannot be stopped and so with Batman
taking to the multiverse in an effort to
find a way to stop the anti-monitor the
scene transitions back to apocalypse
with Lex Luthor and Superman now what's
interesting about this particular point
in time is that with Superman being
virtually powerless due to the lack of a
Yellow Sun his life is literally in the
hands of Lex Luthor because of this
Superman has to resist his normal urge
to distrust Lex and instead less places
trust in him for his own survival from
here the story begins to move into this
series of moments with an overarching
narration by Wonder Woman with the
Justice League teleporting to the
anti-monitor as he awaits the arrival of
Darkseid we get a bit more banter
between Grail and Wonder Woman while
this isn't really important this is
really just John's providing a little
more context to the dichotomy between
the tube and that Grails being depicted
as the antithesis to Wonder Woman
regarding her views on life and a role
in the DC pantheon what I mean here is
that where Wonder Woman serves to ensure
the protection of life and truly
operates as a catalyst for the Amazonian
mission to protect the world Grail
stands as a daughter of Marina who
looked to achieve the same goal but
raised to your daughter for a darker
purpose what John's is doing here is
juxtapose the two together in saying
that they both want the same thing but
light the path of the Jedi and the Sith
from the Star Wars universe the two are
going about them in completely separate
ways and so with dark start arriving due
to grail invoking an Amazonian ritual
Jessica Cruz asked the question of who
they should fight at this point John's
provides one of the best monologues that
I've ever seen in a comic using Greek
mythology as a basis Wonder Woman tells
us the story of Odysseus Chartists and
Scylla in Homer's epic poem Odyssey
Odysseus spent ten years attempt to
return home following his involvement in
the Trojan War during this time he
encountered all manner of Greek gods and
monsters some of whom were benign while
others were malicious during his journey
he encountered charges and Scylla during
his attempt
to cross through the strait of messina
according to legend on one side of the
Straits at Chartists who is hidden
beneath the water but created whirlpools
with giant teeth that would swallow men
and ship alike on the other side sat
Scylla a six-headed monster who would
grab man from their boats and consume
them when Odysseus was forced to make
his way through the strait of messina in
the end he had to choose one side
knowing that there was no way to cross
without taking some kind of loss to the
ranks of his men using this as a
metaphor what John's tells us is the
dark side and anti-monitor represent
these respective monsters with a Justice
League operating as travelers and that
no matter what side they choose whether
it be dark side or anti-monitor there's
no way to escape the situation without
suffering some kind of loss and so as a
story begins to come to a close
Lex Luthor realizes that the fires of
apocalypse are effectively solar pits
and that in order for Superman and
himself to survive the situation Clark
will have to be dropped inside to
recharges energies and so committing to
this act and dropping Clark inside as
Alexis surrounded by slaves attending to
claim his life
Superman emerges as the god of Steel
with that being said we're going to
bring this video to an end and let me
know what you guys think about the story
so far and I will catch you guys later
peace